انا العمليه العسكريه ماضيه في مسارها وان
هناك اهداف ستحققها هذه العمليه بل انه هو
شهر الى انه الان يعني لا يدور الحديث عن
اي استئناف حتى للمفاوضات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وانه الانتقال الى المسار
انتقال من المسار العسكري الى المسار
السلمي الان لا تناقش اي شروط له باعتبار
ان هذه العمليه تسير في مسارها وانها
ستحققها وانا موسكو ماضيه في عمليا فرد
سيطرتها على الاراضي التي تم ضمها مؤخرا
للسياده الروسيه على مدار الايام الماضيه
استمعنا الى تصريحات عديده تفيد بان هناك
تطوير لتسليح القوات الروسيه اعاده نشر
لها بل ان العمليات العسكريه بحسب بيانات
وزاره الدفاع تتوسع في بعض المناطق على
محاور المعارك سواء في او خرسون ايضا في
بامباش بهدف فرض سيطره القوات واستعاده
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه لذلك لا توجد حتى الان مؤشرات
او معطيات سياسيه تفيد بان موسكو يمكن ان
تقدم على ايقاف هذه العمليه والانتقال
لمرحله التفاوض السلمي ولكن هذا لا يمنع
بان موسكو تتعاطى مع المبادره الصينيه
باعتبار من جانب اخر العمليه العسكريه
بشكل اقتصادي بل وعسكري ايضا على روسيا
ولكن يبقى لاي مدى يمكن لهذه المبادره ان
تحقق لموسكو ما تريدون من الاحتفاظها
بمناطق النفوس الاساسيه التي تسعى للسيطره
عليها وبشكل خاص بجزيره القرن وماذا عن
الجديد على ارض خصن معناته
هو مجموع بان التقدم مازال صيدا للموقف
شرق البلاد وجنوب ايضا شرق اوكرانيا
حسب تصريحات الاخيره انها تواصل معاركها
خاصه
التي تشكل مركز دعم لوجستي للقوات
الاوكرانيه لا تحقق انتصاراتها بالفعل
وصلت على حدود هذه المدينه وسيطرت على بعض
البلدات المجاوره لهذه المدينه وبالتالي
تستمر المعارك رغم الوضع الذي تشكو منه
بشكل دائم حول نقص الامدادات وايضا قله
عدد الجنود باعتبار ان وزاره الدفاع اوقفت
عمليات تجنيد المساجين والان تعتمد بشكل
كامل على المتطوعين
العاديين يعني ليس من السجون الروسيه كما
سبق واعتراض على مدار الشهور الماضيه من
ايجاد مقاتلين لمجموعاتي